Nita Terrace Helen Mirren Gandhi I
reckon if Allah to a new litter one
potato atlatl
[Music]
Kylie the hero and the Monocacy lying in
a field known lon
Kenan rotten Atlanta kinds of top
Caselli they would do to flank the
chopper that'll do it in the name of
jihad City Amity Gabe grant London way
salamati we're not only [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you later
Gilmartin Rumaki
[Music]
today the Maquis are one of over a
hundred species of lemur found in
Madagascar almost all of which are
endangered like 90% of Madagascar's
wildlife they are found nowhere else
Madagascar is an ancient island
separated from Africa for over a hundred
and sixty million years much of the land
was once covered by lush rainforests but
now the trees have been felled what
isn't used for agriculture has been left
barren seasonal burning stops the forest
growing back
nestled between towering cliffs a tiny
fragment remains this is under a beacon
of hope and a last refuge for the Maquis
[Music]
concerned that the forest was
disappearing
a group of local people formed a
community association to protect Anza
and the lemurs nan Orrock ma th on the
assertive person in Lhasa cotton-pickin
Bangor er niala our net away mash our
campus our turn a patrulla when he
formula me RC only from the carnival the
same thing Elena Newton and if you
combine allah allah allahu allah ma
- Jennifer tougher case CCP a position
before Sammy seen people entering the
association also established an entrance
fee for the forest which is used to fund
a local school many members now earn
their living taking tourists to see the
lemurs in the forest
a new mocha Tommy nice coffin neurofen
auntie Janet yah myself away sanitary
not only will you turn assist our shreya
is a new phenomena Hajj professional as
Ana Montes narrator Jaffa Campari Tagami
know so sadly the Maquis are the biggest
draw for tourists to Anza as
Madagascar's most famous lemur many
people come here just to see them over
the years they have gradually become
accustomed to people nowadays they have
little to fear from humans but this
wasn't always the case
Deva Katta niolani
timonin a new motto say new latinum
teeny sad the mission has an affinity
follow fajita syndrome annuity
reason the targeted na na moon peep if
only people to one function return a new
litter TT Hampton
mark yeah Mitch when the mullah mantle
mantle on tone peeled
[Music]
as the Association brings real benefits
to the local people they have come to
see the value of the forest that remains
and their feelings towards the animals
are changing to bank food Todd or
sending areas he Allah illallah fearin
reset in Tarzana to vote on a know since
evening we had nativity that me the
mediation
[Music]
[Music]
the refer thousand we accompanied him
talking in a new variant and lucky are
we
Sammy was an hire non-union well-known
peep
[Music]
now that the Association is well
established the true legacy of unser has
become clear
the way the nurses can't in the way who
say his fear abundantly defeated Tanana
and fear of enemy Nyanza tae-young
resistant way larger family / young turk
a cotton ball who was me mission accom
Aparo pharaohs and Tirupati to learn why
and find Roxana bathysphere Evangeline
fear of an antique
[Music]
we love by Jessica paper Cooper's a
ninny
man team BFRO a questions you'll fight
us camisole across Madagascar lemur
populations are drastically declining
but here at Anza the population is over
400 strong for its size unser has the
highest density of marque in Madagascar
the future is uncertain for much of
Madagascar's wildlife but at unser at
least it seems the Maquis are safe
[Music]
you
[Music]